[Música]
a
tengo 16 años y soy un adolescente soy
un adolescente que poco a poco está
descubriendo cómo ser diferente y que es
bueno ser un asociado
que nos puede hacer una sociedad que ha
definido que nosotros tenemos que ver
cómo esta persona perfecta la persona
ideal
estoy segura que a todos ustedes en
clase más de una vez les han dado hojas
de trabajo todas estas son exactamente
iguales fotocopias y si una se pierde
simplemente la reemplazamos con otra y
nunca volvemos a pensar en ella
a lo largo los años descubrí que no
quiero hacer una fotocopia quiero ser
diferente
porque porque quiero dejar mi huella en
asociado quiero que el mundo recuerde
que estoy ahí y si hay más de 7.600
millones de personas en el mundo pero
para los que me conozcan yo quiero ser
la una que haya hecho una diferencia sus
vidas
muchos de nuestra audiencia de hoy son
adolescentes adolescentes que creen que
únicamente existe un molde uno creado
por la sociedad o para hacernos sentir
menos ya que no logramos ser lo que se
espera de nosotros pero hoy vengo a
señales que no tienen que formarse para
caber en él sino que pueden crear el
suyo y que la única opinión que importa
es la de ustedes
ahora necesito que se pongan de pie
siéntense si alguna de esas sus vidas se
han comparado con alguien más
siéntense si alguna de sus sus vidas han
tenido problemas de confianza
siéntense si alguna de sus días ha
sentido que no son lo suficientemente
buenos
miren a su alrededor cuántos de ustedes
aún están de pie
probablemente les dio pena tener que
sentarse o miraron a su alrededor unas
cuantas veces para asegurarse que no
fueran los únicos en hacerlo
esta actividad tan simple nos demuestra
que no estamos solos y nunca lo hemos
estado
un gran porcentaje de los suicidios que
se cometen cada año por parte de
docentes en desarrollo son a causa de
una baja autoestima el suicidio también
siendo la tercera causa de muerte
adolescencia en costa rica
esto es a raíz de falta confiando a sí
mismos
esto es un problema que todos hemos
tenían algún punto nuestra vida
yo lo he tenido le estaría mintiendo se
lo digo que ya no lo tengo
porque aún me siento juzgada cuando
salgo de mi casa aún me siento comparada
con otros si me comparo con otros aún
estoy aprendiendo a aceptar mis
imperfecciones y esta es la palabra
clave en esta charla
debemos aprender que está bien no ser la
persona más deportista la más
inteligente la más popular la persona
que la sociedad ha definido como
perfecta porque en realidad esa persona
no existe
es normal tener problemas de confianza y
la autoestima en esta sociedad y no
debería hacerlo pero esto es porque
vivimos en una sociedad que siento que
es un panel de jueces ya que apenas
salimos de nuestras casas nos sentimos
juzgados por la ropa que andamos la
actitud que tenemos el carro en el que
andamos o en el que no andamos y mucho
más y por lo menos a mí eso me asusta
o me asustado porque un día me detuve a
pensar a quien le dio esa autoridad
y después de pensar un poco me di cuenta
que es autoridad o únicamente se la doy
yo porque las miradas y las críticas
solo me afectan si yo dejo que lo hagan
esto mismo lo dijo el filósofo del
lenguaje de partido en 1965
pero dije
y es cierto que es difícil ignorar todo
esto pero no es imposible ya que lo
hemos hecho miles de veces en el pasado
probablemente está preguntando cuando lo
hemos hecho
y la respuesta a esto es o entramos
niños
parte de esto todo el desarrollo de la
mielina una sustancia que vuelve es
cierto los centros nerviosas del cerebro
cuya función es la de controlar los
impulsos nerviosos
la mielina se va desarrollando a lo
largo de los años por lo que cuando
somos adultos esta sustancia ya cubre
todo nuestro cerebro y debido a ello
somos más capaces de controlar las
acciones impulsivas entonces básicamente
esta sustancia nos previene decir cosas
irracionales o de hacer cosas estúpidas
cuando somos adolescentes aún no
contamos con una cobertura completa a la
mina por lo que muchas de las veces nos
dejamos llevar por nuestras emociones
estamos de manera impulsiva y entonces
ya se pueden imaginar con tramos niños
cuando éramos niños podíamos ir al
supermercado en pijamas
salir con la cara pintada empezar a
hablar en medio centro comercial que se
nos antojaba y si alguien tenía algo que
decir sobre eso era mejor que se lo
guardara porque igual a esa no nos
importa lo que los demás dijeran o
pensarán de nosotros pero por qué
porque estábamos protegidos y no poner
sus padres sino por una capa confianza
una confianza tan poderosa que nos
permitía redactar la autoridad a la
sociedad de hacernos sentir mal pero
junto con los años llega la inseguridad
y el miedo
debido a ello no nos podemos desarrollar
en paz en un ambiente seguro ya que
tenemos miedo a ser rechazados pero la
que nadie nunca toma en cuenta es que es
mejor ser rechazados que rechazar si uno
mismo
nosotros hacemos es tan imposible por
ser aceptados y eso muchas veces incluye
rechazaron dos palabras comprimir
ciertos aspectos de nosotros mismos
por ejemplo para los que no conocen yo
estoy constantemente inventando y
haciendo y diciendo de esos chistes que
todos conocen comentarios
y probablemente antes muy grado pena de
siglos porque tenía miedo a que nadie se
viera o que pensaran que era rara pero
una vez que logre dejar a un lado estos
talleres se convirtieron en algo que
ahora caracteriza a mi personalidad y si
tal vez sea raro pero también es
distinto
cuántas veces les han dicho que son
raros o cuántas veces han pensado que
alguien es raro
yo soy rara y estoy feliz de serlo
día a día la sociedad nos etiqueta y
nosotros no somos etiquetas somos
personas personas que tienen todo el
derecho de expresarse como son y
visualizar como quisieran ser sin miedo
a no ser aceptados pero si les voy a
decir una cosa
no esperen sean aceptados si ustedes
mismos aceptan tanto lo bueno tanto las
cosas buenas como las cosas no tan
buenas
ahora me gustaría hablar sobre el tema
las inseguridades y porque está surgen
esto es porque el mundo está sumergido
en expectativas y realistas expectativas
que han dedicado a otro nivel
especialmente a causa la tecnología las
redes sociales como instagram facebook
los programas de televisión las revistas
entre muchas otras nos han enseñado que
debemos llenar estas expectativas tanto
físicamente como emocionalmente y
mentalmente
tenemos que ser inteligentes tenemos que
tener los cuerpos prefectos tenemos que
tener actitud perfecta para cada
situación
pero estas expectativas simplemente son
inalcanzables y cuando creemos que las
estamos alcanzando siempre siguen
subiendo
no hay ser humano perfecto y no intentan
de serlo
no intenten de perseguir estas
expectativas porque si no se terminarán
aunque 'no en ellas
buenas lágrimas que cayeron cada vez que
no pudieron alcanzar una
se nos ha enseñado que debemos estrujar
en los hijos hermanos para caber en el
molde que la sociedad ha diseñado para
nosotros por lo que muchas veces
comprimimos todas nuestras habilidades y
gustos escondidos y los mantenemos
escondidos y tal vez los desarrollaremos
se convertiría en algo que podrían
definir a nuestra personalidad y hasta
nosotros mismos
a no caer en este molde nos comparamos
con otros y personalmente siento
personalmente siento que esto de las
cosas que no puedas en la autoestima
todos aquí lo hemos hecho en algún punto
de nuestras vidas
desde alguien que vamos a hacer por la
calle
o un amigo hasta una modelo una actriz
porque no puedo tener el pelo así porque
no puedo vestirme así porque no puedo
ser tan inteligente como esa persona
porque no puedo ser más deportista
y se ponen a pensarlo la verdad esas
personas ni siquiera se dan cuenta que
no estamos comparando con ellas por lo
que el daño únicamente no lo hacemos a
nosotros mismos y en nuestra confianza
no les parece que muchas veces queremos
ser como frankenstein cuando nos vemos
al espejo
mi verdadera meta no es si nunca ha sido
verme un espejo y decir ya soy tan
inteligente como tal ya soy tan linda
como tal
porque eso significa que estoy viendo
toda una combinación de diferentes
personas al menos a mí
mi meta es verme un espejo y poder ver
mis imperfecciones
lo vemos todo mis cualidades con amor
y no tratarlas como profesiones sino
como lo que me hace distinta al resto
no no seguimos creyendo que tenemos que
ser perfectos
y tenemos que cumplir con todas las
cosas que la sociedad manda
cuando nada de esto es cierto
podemos nosotros tomar nuestro propio
camino
les cuento que no tenemos que cumplir
con todo lo que la sociedad dice con las
medidas que dicen la belleza es algo
abstracto algo que no se puede definir
según la asociado las mujeres tenemos
que ser altas tenemos que tener una
figura reloj de arena tenemos que
cumplir con las medidas de 90 60 90
y hasta se les exige tener un espacio de
los mundos
a los hombres se les exige ser más altas
en las mujeres
tener mandíbulas fuertes grandes
músculos etcétera etcétera si se les
exige
utilizó esta palabra porque nosotros
sentimos que vamos posee estas
características para ser bellos pero de
benin que ni yo ni ustedes debemos nada
a la sociedad y dos mundos chocan noveno
metro setenta no tenga un busto 90 y
mucho menos una 160 y la verdad no
quiero nada de eso porque me dado cuenta
que yo necesito para ser feliz
y también es importante saber de que
nosotros somos nuestros pobres críticos
nosotros vamos por la vida pensando de
que todo no puede la espinilla que nos
salió a los tres kilos que aumentase o
las ojeras que te salieron por no haber
dormido la noche anterior pensando la
espinilla que te salió y los tres kilos
comentaste
cuando la verdad es que nadie ve nada de
eso
nosotros somos los padres críticos y
nuestra inseguridad acostumbramos todos
nosotros
pero así como los acostumbramos a ver
nosotros vamos a acostumbrarnos a verlo
mejor
en lugar de velas green ya que no salió
concentrémonos en las dos que se nos
quitaron comencemos por cosas pequeñas
pequeños pasos de confianza y si no me
creen recuerden tantas veces de que no a
donde un amigo una amiga y le dice ojo
del monte efe se mueva mi frente y la
amiga le dice que exagerada ni se le ve
llame si no es cierto
estoy segura que muchos de ustedes han
escuchado la canción de selena gomez que
se titula ajustes
la canción también tu mensaje es
sumamente importante de pequeños tal vez
la escuchábamos pero no le ponía mucha
atención a la letra o no la entendíamos
pero ahora que soy mayor puedo
comprender el valor y el poder en esas
palabras
así que le pido que la próxima vez que
lo escuchen ahora en sus oídos la
escuchen con mucha atención
y le abran la puerta en sus corazones a
este mensaje
[Música]
arias
ahora les pido que cierren sus ojos y
piensen en todas las características que
los hacen distintos y de paso también
piensen en sus cualidades
enumera en ambas cosas con sus dedos
este número es completamente privado
nadie más que ustedes lo va a ver en sus
ojos y en sus manos
y hace número que están viendo el número
que están pensando añadirles 5 10 y
hasta 15 porque soy segura que ninguno
de ustedes se da cuenta todas las otras
cualidades que posee
cuando estén solos en sus casas y se
mire en un espejo no dejen que el espejo
refleje solo lo físico vean más allá de
eso
vean con sus ojos y no con los de la
sociedad y cuando lo hagan recuerden que
ustedes no son una cara no son un cuerpo
no sólo una etiqueta no son uno más pero
nunca nunca crean que no son lo
suficientemente buenos
ya hemos desperdiciado suficiente tiempo
pensando y preocupándonos por lo que la
sociedad piense de nosotros y este
tiempo ya no se puede recuperar
pero nunca muy tarde para recuperar la
confianza la sonrisa y empezar a buscar
el amor propio encuentra aún hay tiempo
gracias
[Aplausos]